hoy vamos a hablar de un tema fascinante
donald trump con este vídeo empezamos
una nueva playlist en la que nos vamos a
dedicar a las elecciones americanas un
tema que lógicamente teníamos que tratar
en un canal como éste
donald trump es uno de los candidatos a
las primarias republicanas y hay un
consenso en todo europa en que es idiota
aunque todavía hay gente que piensa que
bueno sino una empresa del éxito como él
no puede no puede equivocarse pocos se
han dedicado a hacer una desgranar sus
propuestas una a una y ver si merece la
pena lo que dice este hombre nosotros lo
hemos hecho y la conclusión que hemos
sacado bueno cauto nos la puede ser
mejor pues son secan la conclusión que
hemos obtenido es que este hombre es un
auténtico peligro público no porque sea
probable que vaya a ser presidente de
eeuu porque lo cierto es que esto es
verdaderamente improbable pero sí por el
caldo de cultivo que está generando en
la política y en la sociedad americana
este personaje populista victimista y
llegó maníaco hoy vamos a ver por qué
fonseca
o sea que no lo sabe donald trump es el
candidato con más papeletas de ganar las
primeras republicanas este año es un
señor que ya era conocido antes de
entrar en política por ser uno de los
hombres más ricos del mundo ahora con
sus propuestas también está demostrando
que es uno de los hombres más fachas del
mundo pero fonseca facha de verdad su
programa electoral es un auténtico
delirio sí porque propone propone
auténticas barbaridades como por ejemplo
deportar a 11 millones de inmigrantes
ilegales mandarles a su casa pero
mandando a la policía así van más que a
toda la población a andalucía mandando a
la policía metiéndoles en camiones y
mandando les de vuelta y es tremendo de
hecho el señor donald trump una de sus
citas más célebres de la campaña es que
él no va a romper las unidades
familiares sonseca porque va a deportar
a los a los papás a las mamás y a los
niños todos juntos lo que es además
inconstitucional porque muchos de esos
niños ya son ciudadanos americanos según
la ces en eeuu el territorio americano
eres ciudadano americana y esa
ciudadanía no estará por largarse que
aparezca el señor donald trump la
constitución americana le importa más
bien poco luego además también propone
le van
un muro una muralla en la frontera entre
eeuu y méxico si si un muro de más de
mil kilómetros con alambradas perros
metralletas y nadie sabe muy bien para
qué porque lo cierto fonseca es que
desde el año 2009 la población
inmigrante mexicana en eeuu se viene
reduciendo y hoy hay más inmigrantes que
llegan cada año de india y china que de
méxico y los emigrar y además fosetas
llegan a un aeropuerto bueno pues claro
que la mitad de los inmigrantes ilegales
han llegado en avión llegan y cuando
hace su visa sé que alberto ese estado
hay en eeuu resultado en california en
nuevo media y nevada fonseca si yo tenía
que tienen la oportunidad de conocer muy
bien eeuu sobre todo los estados del sur
que son los estados en los que más
población hispana y te puedo decir lo
mismo que te diría cualquier persona que
haya estado en el terreno en el lugar y
es que no hay ningún problema ni de
adaptación y de criminalidad con la
población hispana
los hispanos llegarán a estados unidos a
trabajar cuando tú vas a un burger king
o una tienda las personas que te
encuentras en aquellos trabajos con
menor retribución son
y de hecho fonseca te voy a decir más
según todos los estudios la tasa de
delincuencia en términos comparables de
la población hispana es menor que la de
la población que ha nacido en eeuu que
era la población local osea fíjate tú
qué problema que no tiene ningún sentido
la fijación que tiene donald trump con
los mexicanos a los que además quiere
hacer que paguen el muro con un par de
narices el muro es que cuesta 8.000
millones de dólares quiere que lo pague
el gobierno mexicano no muy bien no
entiendo muy bien cómo les va a
convencer pero bueno esto funciona
encaja muy bien con el espíritu
imperialista del señor donald trump
porque no sólo quiere pagar no quiere
hacer pagar el muro a los mexicanos es
que además ha anunciado que a todos los
europeos nos va a hacer pagar un tributo
a los eeuu en cuestión de defensa y que
además también va a ir a los países de
oriente medio como arabia saudita y les
va a hacer pagar también un tributo como
si fuesen países vasallos como si fuese
colonia del siglo 19 imaginas tú te
imaginaste donald trump viendo ahí
hablar con el rey de arabia saudi
diciéndole oye mira que me tener que
pagar aquí el impuesto así porque va a
salir de donde no te digo y es que no
tiene ningún sentido pero fíjate ha
llegado a decir que va a invadir
militarmente irak y siria
o sea y gran parte de oriente medio y
que se va a quedar directamente con el
petróleo porque dice que va a pagar la
ocupación militar con el petróleo que
directamente va a explotar en irak y en
otros países de oriente medio sea
imagínate pero como si fuésemos técnicas
colonias ya te digo un embargo en la
economía en lo que es la política
económica se parece más a pablo iglesias
que angela merkel desde luego fonseca de
hecho la mayor fijación que tiene el
señor donald trump es contra el libre
comercio y está totalmente en contra del
libre comercio está en contra el tratado
libre comercio que se está negociando
entre europa y eeuu está en contra del
tratado de libre comercio que
recientemente se ha aprobado entre eeuu
y países del pacífico incluso
el tratado entre canadá méxico y eeuu
que es un tratado que lleva 20 años en
funcionamiento y lo quiere lo quiere
quitar o sea el tío no es para nada pero
negocio ni muchísimo no todo lo
contrario de hecho fíjate el nafta que
ha sido todo un éxito volvió al caso de
méxico es que el nafta ha conseguido que
las relaciones comerciales entre estados
unidos y méxico se alcancen cada año y
los 500 mil millones de euros médicos ya
es el tercer socio comercial de eeuu y
genera mucho éxito 2 millones después de
trabajo en eeuu sin embargo como ven
populista quiere triplicar el gasto
público porque dice que quiere gastar
muchísimo más en el ejército y si
quieren gastar mucho más en el ejército
porque dice fonseca que el ejército de
los eeuu es muy pequeñito a pesar de que
hoy ya gastan más que los 20 países
siguientes en el ranking juntos pero no
sólo el ejército es que también ha
anunciado que quiere llenar el país de
trenes de alta velocidad de autopistas y
de infraestructuras todo tiene que no
tiene nada que ver con la austeridad de
merkel por ejemplo nada más lejos de
merkel pero además el señor donald trump
física quiere realizar la cuadratura del
círculo no sólo quiere aumentar el gasto
público
no solo quiere cerrar sus mercados al
libre comercio sino que además también
ha dicho que prácticamente va a eliminar
la mayor parte de los impuestos por
ejemplo el impuesto sociedades el
impuesto a los beneficios de las
empresas lo va a eliminar cuando en eeuu
están convertidos 40 p de singapur y sil
de paraíso fiscal pero es que el
impuesto a la renta ha dicho que el tipo
máximo va a bajar del 40 por ciento al
15 pocos países en el mundo tienen esos
tipos y por supuesto gastando más yo he
oído que es el candidato favorito de
putin
o sea que putin ha dicho públicamente
que si él fuera americano votaría y
donald trump en la correspondido fonseca
diciendo que putin es uno de sus
referentes políticos si imagínate que
para un aval dice ya mucho de él
el campeón o sea si putin te apoya es
que algo estás haciendo mal sí pero ya
sabes consiga que todo el mundo dice que
como ha sido un gran empresario y un
empresario mucho éxito que eso le avala
a su proyecto político es que tampoco ha
sido y ahí estoy ahí estoy de ahí estoy
en desacuerdo porque no ha sido un gran
empresario realmente fue un tío que
heredó la empresa de su padre que era
una empresa inmobiliaria que ya por
aquel entonces en los años 70 era una
empresa multimillonaria y bueno hay
algunos estudios que dicen que si en vez
de continuar el negocio lo hubiera
vendido todo y lo hubiera invertido en
bolsa bolsa en un valor normal y
corriente o sea en el standard and
poor's sin más ahora mismo sería más
rico de lo que ya es con lo cual está no
de hecho fonseca ha rozado en muchas
ocasiones la auténtica bancarrota
empresarial y también personal y además
siempre todos sus negocios ante un euro
leo una aureola de juego sucio siempre
ha estado al límite de la ley por
ejemplo pues para impar en no pagar a
trabajadores o no pagar a proveedores
cuando las empresas iban mal o quebraron
la cadena de casinos que tenían
a los trabajadores claro porque cuando
justo antes de que declarase la la
quiebra fonseca sabía de ese orden atrás
había cercenado de saquear la caja de la
empresa pagándose comisiones de gestión
salarios bueno y por todo tipo de
conceptos o auténtica reformulación
diríamos que es un payaso pero un payaso
peligroso o no un payaso peligroso y
además misógeno porque fíjate fonseca
sabes lo que ha llegado a decirle señor
donald trump señor donald tram ha
llegado a decir que hillary clinton no
sería una buena presidenta porque ha
sido incapaz de satisfacer sexualmente a
su marido pero que puedes imaginar cuál
es el nivel político de bueno oye cauto
pues vamos a tener que cerrar yo creo
que ya hemos dejado claro
lo que propone el señor trump y bueno
solamente decir que por favor que no si
alguien quiere añadir algo está en
desacuerdo de lo que decimos por lo que
sea piensa que donald trump ha venido
para recambiar para reformar la política
americana y quiere defender o hay algún
votante de donald trump o el mismo señor
donald etra mismo quiere mandarnos algo
un comentario deja de ser un único
problema fonseca es que ya sabes que si
se produce la rocambolesca situación de
que acabase siendo presidente eeuu cosa
que es muy improbable porque no se
pueden ganar unas elecciones en eeuu sin
contar con el apoyo de las minorías
sobre todo de la población negra y de la
población hispana que nosotros
estaríamos automáticamente en una lista
negra sí bueno tendremos tendremos que
ver qué pasa para para que el entonces
bueno oye cauto un abrazo y perfecto
fonseca un fuerte abrazo y oye hasta
otro día